so I want to ask about this video this
is you traveling in Utah you like to
travel I love this so wait what's
Happening Here
at least
a good time I'm warming up my vocal
cords that's really good for the yeah do
you are you like an adrenaline junkie
I'm so the opposite of an adrenaline
junkie
um but I you know my mom was really
um I I'm very grateful to my mother for
so many different reasons but she was
always like do hard things do scary
things push yourself I don't know if
that's what she meant um like go on a
bridge 700 or 500 600 feet in the air
but um you know I I don't like doing
things like that but I push myself too
and I'm always glad that I wow I do you
know so that um was an experience for
sure I didn't 100 know what I was
getting myself into when I said I would
go rock climbing uh uh but that's hard I
know have you ever done anything like
that well no I don't have that no no
people are like you I did like indoor
one time and I was like I'm out I got
like three of I just I was like super
athletic early 20s and like then like
previous and then like after I just was
tired I just got tired and I was like no
I'm like I want but I'll hold you down
I'll be the anchor at the bottom I want
someone to trick me into going skydiving
like ASAP because if I don't do it now I
you know what I mean I gotta get that
out of the way my sister and my friend
did it for their birthdays and I was
like you know what no gonna do it and I
was like it works really hard for this
one I'm not dying yeah yeah no it's a
bad way to go out if it's going down and
it's the only option
sure right I'll jump right aisle yeah
somebody I know that did it said like
you're gonna you have to do it because
you all you want to do is get out of
that plane because it's so small and
rickety they're like I'm so happy to
jump out and fly on into the sky because
it's that part is so much scarier yeah
my sister loved it so did my friend but
I was like that's so good for you it's
so nice yeah like the videos of people
when they land and they're like
yeah okay I'll just walk around right
now and say it like I need to do
something risky to be happy about it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]